this was a decisive result uh 80
of criminal barristers who voted in this
ballot voted in favor of escalating the
industrial action which actually began
at the end of june and in 19
days of industrial action between that
period and up to the beginning of august
more than 6 000 cases were disrupted 1
400 of those were trials so now what
we're talking about is an indefinite
all-out strike which would start on
september the 5th however there are some
barristers who were already
due to strike this week and so for them
they actually will not work
at all uh from this point now because of
the dates um
except that september the fifth date and
it's all over pay now you might think
criminal barristers earn a lot of money
and the fact is that they get their
money from
legal aid and according to them
in real terms that money the fees they
get have fallen by 28 in recent times
the government is offering them 15
percent which in itself
doesn't sound bad however the barristers
say they need 25
more in legal aid fees to be able to do
their work and earn enough money and
earlier i spoke to jennifer de vans to
macklow who is quite early on in her
career as a criminal barrister but she
said that when you work things out
sometimes she's earning little more than
the minimum wage this is what she had to
say
we have to consider as self-employed
individuals is that we i've come to
wolverhampton today which is not my home
court i pay my expense of getting here
up front nobody is helping me out with
that now if you're going around the
country as people from my chambers do
and people from many other chambers will
do you have to bear those costs up front
you have to do all the proprietary work
that simply isn't covered by the fees
that you ultimately get at the end of
proceedings so people the government
needs to understand the hardships that
criminal barristers like myself like
those who have been here before me and
like those who might choose to follow
are facing
now there'd already been an immense
backlog in the criminal justice system
before
uh the pandemic came along and added to
that problem
and in the past year according to
jennifer 300 criminal barristers have
left the profession and that she says is
all adding to this backlog because there
simply aren't the numbers of staff to do
the work which is why more money is
needed for these legal aid fees now as
far as the government is concerned they
are very unimpressed and there has been
a statement from
the justice minister sarah dines who
said this is an irresponsible decision
that will only see more victims face
further delays and distress the
escalation of strike action is wholly
unjustified considering we're increasing
criminal barristers fees by 15 percent
which will see the typical barrister
earn around 7 000 pounds more a year as
far as the criminal bar association is
concerned this action is a necessity
they say it is a last resort action